okay so I personally have come to love
Bioware games in particular
Mass Effect I mean there's something
really awesome about a game that makes
it feel like the fate of the galaxy
literally rests in your hands by the
choices you make and having the choices
you make early on in the game effect
events later in the game I mean that is
an awesome feeling love that Mass Effect
and now legendary Pictures has acquired
the rights to make a mass effect movie
next feelings about that I want to like
this idea but as we've seen in the past
video game movies are nothing more than
mediocrity wrapped in half-ass attempts
in the middle of a [ __ ] script now the
reason I don't think a mass effect movie
it's gonna be the great idea that people
want it to be is because what makes Mass
Effect great is you the player the
actions that you take in the game shape
how the story unfolds it's like those
choose your own adventure books only a
sweet-ass sci-fi told through a
videogame and if you take that element
away and make it a linear plot in a
movie at least you'll have the
characters and story arcs to fall back
on right because movies are only two
hours long and Mass Effect literally has
hours upon hours of character driven
story arcs and plots 95% of which will
have to be cut out in order to make it a
movie it'd be kind of like translating a
fifteen hundred page book into a two
hour movie you know it wouldn't be able
to be done without them cutting a [ __ ]
ton of the story out yeah those loyalty
missions that you loved in Mass Effect 2
yeah they won't be in the movie they
can't be the movie would be like 9 hours
long that's if they make a Mass Effect 2
after the first movie I mean let's face
it sci-fi movies aren't usually you know
good I mean you have your exceptions you
have your original Star Wars trilogy
you're JJ Abrams Star Trek [ __ ] you even
have the Wrath of Khan but for every one
of those you have a hundred other
Chronicles of Riddick sand species and
every other piece of [ __ ] that's taking
up the other 99% and if you look at
video games video games are not what
they used to be at all they used to be
these simple time killers with simple
plots and Hollywood couldn't translate
that into a proper movie so why should
we believe that they can translate Mass
Effect I mean if you look at it video
games are a medium in which you can tell
the story like movies and books they
unfold a story in a way that's unique to
that format by putting you in the
driver's seat it's like all that talk
about an uncharted movie there's a part
of me that would just love to see that
but ultimately like Mass Effect
Uncharted is a playable movie however
rushed or not it'd still be better than
that which should not be named and I
know there are people who don't play
video games so the natural thing is all
this should make a mass effect movie for
those people who don't play games that
just seems kind of lazy to me that's
like someone saying well I don't read
books oh you should make that book into
a movie see the similarity
it's kind of similar and something tells
me they're gonna get Channing Tatum or
Sam or than tend to be Shepard and mass
effect just have a feeling I'm calling
it now so a mass effect movie do you
think it's a good idea or another [ __ ]
sci-fi movie based off a video game it's
just jonesing for the Razzie Awards
comment below
oh and if you haven't played Mass Effect
yet
seriously dude go play Mass Effect